it's one of the things that I learned
from watching Bourdain's original show
the No Reservations show and that it
changed my opinion on things because I
didn't have a strong opinion on food
before that other than that I really
liked it I didn't think of it as an art
form and watching his show and seeing
the passion his his appreciation for
food and for the way it's the way it's
grown and brought to table and the
production of it and and then ultimately
the flavor of it and the taste and and
his admiration for chefs and and you
guys as well his his advertising for it
and his appreciation for the way
everything's put together made me
realize oh this is an art form it's a
craft and and you know Tony did
something Tony was the most faithful
most like we were so lucky to be on that
ship with him you know that he took us
aboard and you could see he had the same
apprenticeship we did you know like
suffering and like big Bistro kitchens
and stuff and you think about it the guy
he didn't make the promise to himself
that when he'd get rich and famous he
was gonna buy a big house and not talk
to people he helped every cook not walk
out of the kitchen and get famous but
get a voice you know when I was in
television show the work he did in
private and not look like a dirty guy
that makes the pasta in the back you
know all of a sudden it's like yeah the
the manager in the suit and the owners
but who's the guy in the back yeah you
know no he had an appreciation for
everybody and he had a real passion for
the process
yeah marginal character is you know
there's lots of commercial restaurants
in the city of Montreal in any given
city that he went to he's able to
isolate let's say the marginal
characters in every city that you know
we're you know we're historically bound
kind of Fred and I practice a weird
faction of French cooking called cuisine
bourgeoise and only kind of Tony and a
handful of other guys couldn't look at
what we do and go [ __ ] there they're
up to that no one generated you guys are
the only people like the last of the
mohicans that do this kind of
dude and we know you know we can't stop
we got to keep on with like what a great
guy to get it yeah because nobody does
right nobody understands like you know
the the rabbit-hole were down Tony did
you know the cognoscenti yeah he mean he
really did deeply influence my
appreciation for food the way I think
about it and again
treating it as an art form which I just
thought it was just delicious I didn't
think of it as like oh these guys are
making temporary art to making art
you're gonna you're gonna enjoy now you
know and you you you you can't put it on
film I mean you can but you're not gonna
get it all you're just gonna want to go
out and experience it yeah ultimately
food is you can't we go and do like we
were asked to do like demonstrations you
know you can go in a big stage it's
5,000 people to talk about food or make
like little crackers with smoked salmon
onstage food is not fit for a stage food
is for a table for us to enjoy you know
what a fork and I if we talk about it
and go hunting that's that's what food
is people offers food shows all the time
and I mean I can't doesn't work you know
it's like what's the concept well you
guys can be in a pickup truck and you go
and visit your suppliers and maybe I
have a bottle of wine with them after I
was like dude like we worked hard not to
copy or like fellow you know culinarians
yeah you look at 4 seconds ours TV
producers are out there just like
blatantly proposing the previous show to
you again
you know well that's one of the things
right after Anthony died there was some
talk about vacuum MZ doing some very
similar show and the outcry against it
was enormous I mean he was just getting
assaulted online it was crazy
everybody that I was talking to our
agent who did represents us for our book
and she was saying like that was the
same all the big production companies
like are being berated by people
pitching who's gonna be the next Tony
right you know I don't want to say that
but one of the character and you guys
and
you could take over yeah you could do
you guys Trent you know the way it went
in West Virginia and it wasn't like
Republican Democrat he went to places
he's like yeah sure I have my views but
let's break bread you know and I always
said that that like all our countries
are divided on issues but there are
nobody that overlaps them with a
coherent vision everybody loves each
other when there's delicious food on the
table man yeah and guys like you with
like a clear view and irrational and
science-based and evidence-based view on
things and like Tony just have such a
voice now in our countries that it's I
could see you doing a food show I love
food I don't I'll never do a food show
and I just can't imagine because you ask
questions I like doing shows I mean I
love having guys like you want and
talking about food but it takes a
special type of person to want to travel
300 days a year you know and that's
essentially what Tony was doing and I
think that has a massive toll it takes a
massive toll on your body it takes a
massive toll on your psyche family
everything else it's not healthy there's
not enough melatonin or like CBD or like
cleanses to help you with that
I traveled more than enough already and
I've cut my traveling way back I'm down
to only ten UFC's a year now and I do
you know comedy around that and stand-up
comedy but I consciously make the effort
to travel much less because I just don't
think it's good I just don't think it's
good for you and and also that road life
you know the the drinking and all that
other stuff that comes with it that
accentuates all the problems that you
have with with travel and I think that's
also one of the things that was was
dragging Tony down when he would talk
about the sadness and the loneliness of
being on the road I can't help but from
knowing him and partying with him I
can't help but thought that a lot of
that was probably accentuated by the
alcohol consumption and you know and you
guys could speaker that now that your
your your clean and your
not experiencing those rugged hangovers
every morning I was always worried for
Tony that way just said you know that
Hotel living planes trains and
automobiles constantly and it wasn't
like for a year it was like hey its own
twelve years a sad life it to watch
River Monsters at 11:00 in the morning
burping Jameson and I'm referring to
many occasions in our lives where you're
like you're travelling in a hotel room
and you're in a beautiful place but like
it just you feel weird yeah yeah yeah
I've taken steps to mitigate some of
that and one of the big ones is I travel
with friends I bring really good comics
to work with me on the road so that when
I'm in these cities I'm in these cities
with friends and we just go it's like
their family so we we go we'll go eat
together we'll go work out together you
know and try to keep the unhealthy [ __ ]
to a minimum